pour tenter de remonter le moral des
consommateurs les soldes s'affiche dans
toutes les vitrines du centre-ville de
munich depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine les ménages allemands bund les
achats non essentiels
le ralentissement de l'économie se fait
plus sentir en allemagne qu'ailleurs en
europe et l'inflation a dépassé les 7%
au mois de mars du jamais vu depuis 30
ans
malgré la levée des restrictions
sanitaires la guerre en ukraine et
l'inflation pèse beaucoup sur le moral
des consommateurs
dans le monde entier la guerre en
ukraine à trois principales conséquences
sur l'économie la hausse des prix des
produits alimentaires la hausse du prix
de l'énergie et la pénurie d'engrais
dont kiev et moscou sont deux importants
exportateurs
pour la banque mondiale ces trois
facteurs pourrait déclencher une
récession mondiale l'europe la chine et
les états unis connaissent d'ores et
déjà une croissance plus lente
l'europe fait face à un plus grand
risque de récession que les états unis à
cause des prix du gaz naturel et sa
grande dépendance cette énergie ne crois
pas que l'europe avait pris les
dispositions nécessaires séraphin cette
situation ont par exemple maintenir les
centrales nucléaires en allemagne
l'économie chinoise a été
particulièrement touchée en raison des
confinement qui ont lieu encore dans
certaines villes comme ici à shanghai
nous avons fermé le 31 mars et nous
avons rouvert le 22 avril près de 70%
nos employés sont de retour et ont
repris le travail en circuit fermé
nous sommes à 70 % nos capacités de
production
avec le co vide 19 et la guerre en
ukraine la banque mondiale revoit ses
prévisions à la baisse la croissance
mondiale pour 2022 estimée à 4,1 pour
cent le mois dernier a été recalculé à
3,2 pour cent